-Thank you very much.
Enjoy yourself. Enjoy yourself.
Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
You're here.
Thank you for watching.
Thank you.
Well, guys,
everyone's talking about
the legal case of the century.
And we finally got our answer.
Gwyneth Paltrow
was found not responsible
for her ski accident.
[ Applause ]
Of course, the other big news
is that former President Trump
was indicted
for the hush-money payment
he made to porn star
Stormy Daniels.
Trump...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Trump is like, "I didn't do it.
I didn't do it.
And if I did do it,
I barely did it.
My first witness is Stormy.
Did I do it?"
"Well, we..."
"Technically, Your Honor,
we didn't actually do it."
But I don't know.
Everyone is talking
about Trump's indictment.
The news is so huge
that even CNN was like,
"We're back, baby!"
Of course, some people
are worried that Trump's arrest
will create division
in the country.
Right.
'Cause we were just having
one big old pizza party
before this.
I read that Trump and his team
were caught off guard
by the news as they thought
any potential indictment
was weeks away.
Not great when everyone's like,
"We knew you'd go to jail.
We just didn't think
it'd be so soon, you know?
Chance to say goodbye to you."
Of course, after the news broke,
Trump got on social media
and started ranting.
And in one post,
instead of writing "indicted,"
he accidentally wrote
"indicated."
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Then when asked how he'll plead,
Trump wrote "Nut Gravy."
♪♪
-That's what
he got in trouble for!
-"Not guilty."
♪♪
-Stormy!
-Meanwhile...
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, people are wondering
how Trump's gonna
get out of this.
And Trump says that you can read
all about it in his new book,
"The Art of the Plea Deal."
And -- And get this.
I read that
Manhattan prosecutors
are also investigating
a second hush-money payment
that Trump might have made
for another affair.
Right now Trump's panicking.
He's like, "O-M-G.
What if Stormy finds out
I cheated on her?"
♪♪
But if Trump is convicted,
he could be imprisoned
for four years --
or two years with good behavior.
So...four years.
[ Laughter ]
But here's some
good news for Trump.
Even if he is convicted,
he can still run for president.
And he can still hold rallies
because a lot of his supporters
are also in prison.
"January 6th? January 6th?
January 6th?
Come over to my table."
Yeah, there's a good chance
Trump could be
the first candidate with a
cellmate for a running mate.
[ Laughter ]
Some business news.
Tesla just launched its own beer
called GigaBier.
Yeah. It's a Tesla beer.
It's the only beer that explodes
even if you don't shake it.
[ Laughter ]
Not gonna stop me from drinking.
-Yeah.
-Some more business news.
I saw that McDonald's stock
just closed at an all-time high.
Yeah, also closing
at an all-time high --
the 16-year-old
McDonald's manager, Kyle.
[Sleepily] "Alright.
We're closed, man.
[ Giggles ]
We can't serve breakfast any --
Oh, sorry. We can't
serve breakfast any..."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, McDonald's stock
is through the roof,
which must mean Trump
has started packing for prison.
That's...
Yeah, I heard that the FDA
will now require medical devices
to be secured
against cyberattacks.
Did you see that?
It's a little frightening when
you're getting an ultrasound
and you hear...
[Russian accent]
"Congratulations. It is boy."
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, today is
the very last day of March,
so I thought it'd be nice
to give a little recap
of the entire month.
Here we go. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Finally the end of March ♪
♪ The Madness has been
off the charts ♪
♪ A crazy month of basketball
thinking... ♪
♪ Time for Taylor's Eras Tour ♪
♪ Can't get seats,
did you get yours? ♪
♪ Ticketmaster getting bashed,
going down like... ♪
-The Gwyneth Paltrow ski crash.
-♪ TikToks where
we love to scroll ♪
♪ The government
might ban it, though ♪
♪ But if Biden lets that fly,
his re-election can... ♪
-Say goodbye.
-♪ A.I. is here
and gaining steam ♪
♪ I'm scared of that ChatGPT ♪
♪ Twitter's business in the
tank, still better than... ♪
-Silicon Valley Bank.
[ Laughter ]
-♪ Yeah, the Oscars
were this month ♪
♪ "Everything, Everywhere,
All at Once" ♪
♪ Next year,
it could be "John Wick" ♪
♪ The only star not on... ♪
-♪ Oh, oh, oh, Ozempic ♪
[ Laughter ]
-♪ Pascal is in every show ♪
♪ We can't get enough Pedro ♪
♪ "Succession" is back
at nine o'clock ♪
♪ If you don't watch,
then, just... ♪
-[Bleep] off!
-Whoa!
-♪ Massive news
we got last night ♪
♪ Jury choosing to indict ♪
♪ Trump will act like he's
Shaggy, when he says... ♪
-It wasn't me.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-It's just -- Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Shagg-ee? Shagg-ee.
-Shagg-ee. Shagg-ee.
-Wow.
-Shagg-ee.
-♪ It wasn't me ♪
-That's right.
♪ It was the third month
of the year ♪
♪ Shamrock Shakes
and cold green beer ♪
♪ Chilly weather,
I've had plenty ♪
♪ So let's heat things up
on 4/20 ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We have a great show.
Chris Pratt is here!
Elizabeth Vargas is joining us!
And we have music
from Maisie Peters.
Let's go write
some Thank You Notes.
Come on, now.
[ The Roots rapping ]
♪♪
-Hey!
Happy Friday, everybody.
Today is Friday.
And that's usually when I catch
up on some personal stuff.
I check my inbox, I return
some e-mails, of course,
and I write out some
Thank You Notes on Fridays.
Yeah, I do it every --
I was just --
I was just wondering.
I'm running a bit behind today.
I thought, if you guys
wouldn't mind, I'd like to write
out my weekly Thank You Notes
right now during the show.
Is that okay?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you very much.
James, can I get some Thank
You Note writing music, please?
♪♪
Alright.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, he's good.
-Chewing gum? What?
-Yeah. I don't know.
♪♪
Thank you,
Major League Baseball's
new 15-second pitch clock.
15 seconds
might not seem that long,
or, as Stormy Daniels put it,
"I beg to differ."
-Whey! Ohh!
Indicated. Lick it.
-No.
♪♪
Thank you, Florida Atlantic's
mascot Owlsley,
for looking like
the world's angriest Cinnabon.
Mad.
[ Laughter ]
-Err!
-He's mad, but delicious.
-He's mad but delicious!
Get a six-pack.
-Thank you, the people who keep
their ID and credit cards
in their phone case,
for saying to the world,
"Eh, if I lose something,
it might as well be everything."
[ Laughter ]
"Just take it all.
Just take it all!"
-"Just take it all."
-Well, can you call your wife?
-No. I can't even -- No.
Legally married anymore.
My wedding certificate's
in it, too.
-The deed to my house.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you, glass,
for being the one thing
that's worth more stained.
-Ohh. Nice.
That's a thinker.
Yeah, that's a thinker.
-That's one of those --
You snap to that one.
-That's a snapper.
-Yeah. You don't clap.
You think about it,
and you go...
-"Yeah, Daddy-o. I grock."
-Let me do it again.
I'll finish it up again.
Try it again. Ready?
[ Clears throat ]
-Everybody snap.
-Thank you, glass,
for being the one thing
that's worth more stained.
[ Fingers snapping ]
[ Jazz music plays ]
-I can dig it.
♪♪
Yeah, man.
He's a cool cat.
-Yeah.
-He's got his pen.
[ Music stops ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you, Cinderella,
for being the beautiful story
of a woman
who catfishes a prince.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-"My shoe."
♪♪
-Thank you, third time guessing
a computer password,
for letting me know
the feeling of what it's like
to defuse a bomb.
[ Laughter ]
"Yes! We're in!
Cut the blue wire!"
♪♪
Thank you, sinks with
hot and cold faucets,
for making me feel like
a water deejay.
There you have it, everybody.
Those are my Thank You Notes.